[Music]
this is ping
a southern three-banded armadillo
predators look elsewhere you'll have a
hard time cracking open this critter
like all armadillos they are covered by
bony plates that make up their shell but
the southern three-banded armadillo is
the only armadillo species that can roll
themselves into a near-perfect bowl when
threatened
these little guys are native to central
south america and prefer dry vegetation
there they feed off insects that they
dig up with their sharp powerful claws
and gather with long sticky straw-like
tongue
but even body armor can't protect this
species from numerous human-made threats
on top of a dwindling habitat they are
hunted heavily for food and the pet
trade
this is the southern three-banded
armadillo
[Music]
this is goliath a galapagos tortoise
he is massive
at over 520 pounds he's one of the
biggest tortoises in the world
goliath is believed to be in his 80s
galapagos tortoises have been known to
live over 150 years
they can go extended periods of time
without food or water
up to a year
this unfortunately led to human
exploitation sailors on ships would
bring these slow-moving defenseless
giants on long voyages as a source of
meat
by the 1970s only about 3 000 were left
but through conservation and breeding
efforts there are now over 20 000
they've become a flagship species for
conservation efforts throughout the
galapagos
but poaching and habitat loss are still
a very real threat
this is the galapagos tortoise
[Music]
this is pierce
an african crested porcupine
the largest porcupine in the world it
can weigh over 60 pounds
when alarmed its coarse quills can be
raised into a crest making themselves
look a lot bigger than they are
it is mostly heavily armored in its
hindquarters which have short thick
quills
these quills can get stuck into its
predator's skin
a good weapon when dealing with hyenas
leopards and even lions
pierce is mostly a herbivore eating
roots bulbs and crops along with the
occasional insect
unfortunately for his species crested
porcupines are seen as an agricultural
pest
and as open land rapidly shrinks they
come into closer quarters with farmers
who will hunt them out of their home
this is the african crested porcupine
[Music]
this is the red knee tarantula
she's got quite the outfit
unfortunately her striking features have
made her a hot commodity in the illegal
pet trade
found in the forests of southwestern
mexico
red needs are some of the largest
spiders growing up to eight inches in
size
besides size their beautiful red white
black and orange hairs are what
separates them from other spiders
the hairs on their legs are used to
sense vibrations from predators and prey
they prey on large insects frogs and
mice biting and injecting them with
their venom
their alluring look has made them the
most popular captive tarantula
causing a major population decline
today regulations are in place requiring
permits to remove any of these beauties
from the wild
this is the red knee tarantula
this is the adra gazelle
this gorgeous gazelle is sadly on the
verge of extinction
once spread across the sahara desert it
is now only found in pockets of chad
molly and niger
adras are considered the largest type of
gazelle with very long legs
they're built lean and slender to
survive the desert heat
their tan and brown coats blend with
their native surroundings
they travel in herds together they
browse and graze grass and leaves
their strength in numbers is a survival
tactic as they count lions leopards and
cheetahs as their predators
in the last decade their population has
decreased by over 80 percent
along with habitat destruction poaching
and over hunting for horns and meat have
caused the adra to become critically
endangered
and some estimate their numbers at less
than 300 in the wild
this is the adra gazelle
[Music]
this is cruz
he's a malayan taper
and he is hungry
[Music]
malayan tapas are the largest of the
four species of tapar and are the only
one native to asia
a close relative of the horse and
rhinoceros tapers have poor eyesight but
their sense of hearing and smell are
finely tuned
if threatened or frightened they've been
known to demonstrate pretty quick bursts
of speed
they are also excellent swimmers and
will seek refuge from predators in deep
water while using their flexible nose as
a snorkel
although they are vegetarians they can
also defend themselves with a bite from
their razor-sharp teeth
their distinctive black and white coat
looks very smart and also serves as an
excellent camouflage
predators will often mistake a taper for
a large rock when they lie down to sleep
despite these adaptations tapers are
extremely threatened
deforestation and encroaching human
development like flooding from
hydroelectric projects are all threats
to their shrinking habitat
this is the malayan taper
[Music]
this is kami a red ruffed lemur
her world is small and it's shrinking
daily
the red ruff's lemur comes by its name
honestly
it's covered in a brilliant chestnut
coat
the rest of its body its face hands
belly and tail are a deep black of the
hundreds of species of lima in
madagascar the red ruffed lemur is one
of the most endangered
found only on a single peninsula in the
northwest of the island country the
rainforest the red raft lima coal home
are also highly valued for the beautiful
rosewood and ebony trees that grow there
it's in the canopy of these trees that
you can find these lemurs
there they search for fruit which makes
up nearly their whole diet
their home forests are being harvested
at an alarming rate
taking the red rough lemur's chance of
survival with them
conservationists estimate that there are
only three to five thousand left in the
wild
this is the red raft lemur
[Music]
this is amalie
she's an addict
she's also a new mom
her calf adeline is just three weeks old
and she's very important
because the addicts is a critically
endangered species
the addicts is a native of the sahara
desert and once roamed over vast areas
of north africa
they're also known as the screw horn
antelope
it's easy to see why
they are extremely well adapted to life
in the desert
their white coats reflect the scorching
sun and their splayed hoofs are
perfectly tailored for traversing desert
sands
the addicts can also survive extremely
long periods without water
but these adaptations are no help
against humans
the addicts has been hunted nearly into
oblivion
estimates put their population at less
than 200 individuals in just a few
pockets of the sahara
luckily reintroduction efforts and
captive breeding programs like the one
that produce little adeline are helping
the survival of this species that has
all but disappeared from the face of the
earth
this is the addicts
[Music]
you